[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gêne et du pape et depuis l'année de
la nuit des temps il ya trois rumeurs
qui ont circulé la terre serait plate
les américains n'auraient jamais marché
sur la lune et anthony des marseillais
auraient commis de la boulette avec ça
un joli apparemment je vous le dis
anthony et sarah il ya eu un bail
c'est ce que voilà tu sais que j'ai un
petit peu dans l'est dans les dos
cette fois c'est julie authentique est
passé en mode jean jacques bourdin pour
faire cracher le morceau anthony hill le
harcèle de questions et on sent que le
pauvre anthony hill et on angoisse 3000
ils essaient de résister à la pression
mais malheureusement anthony va faire ce
qu'on appelle désormais dans le milieu
de l'audiovisuel une jérôme cahuzac a
rien c'est mon ami depuis très longtemps
et voilà rien de plus chez même pas
qu'on revient encore sur le sujet pour
bâtir et il n'y a pas eu de remise ou
non bah non au projet à une bise au soir
soit joue pas on est dans l'instant
terminons et des canettes esprits
non qu'ils pensent qu'il n'a pas touché
maintenant qu'ils pensent qu'il avait au
début dérapages des lieux quelque chose
[Musique]
oui quelque chose le podium on dirait le
web avec mes poteaux sans déconner
sheila pas mais moi quand derrière nous
il a eu finalement j aime me saouler oui
à l'origine est ressentie adore les
problèmes et il en a fait sa marque de
fabrique c'est les problèmes les
problèmes et c'est pour ça que ça plaît
beaucoup aux productions et qu'il est
indispensable maintenant dans l'été
nador c'est parce qu'il fait toute
l'histoire il va lui rapporter secret
des trucs des machins et il adore vous
mettre des problèmes ça le dérange pas
mais vous savez comme moi je veux pas
mais moi je fais des week-ends entiers
comme ça exige accessoires c'est ce même
les problèmes j'ai besoin dire qu'on
s'était passé un truc avec by day - des
mots mais j'adore très dark away
alors pour trouver un peu plus de
légèreté on file tout de suite dans la
bataille des poupe sur tf6
enfin j'aimerais qu'on regarde
rapidement le comte instar de mélanie
mélanie vous connaissez mais l'addition
c'est votre copie non plus alors
regardez je prends des photos comme ça à
faire photo a fait le buzz même aux
états unis juste avant ses intrigues
dans ce cadre et par le grand cabaret
sébastien alors qu'on tortionnaires
quand même nom mais en tout cas et elle
et elle est magnifique et d'essai bref
alors moi c'est pas du tout mon délire
et vous le savez sûrement la lazio faire
rêver sauf quand elle boit trop vite son
cocktail là tout s'effondre regardez il
ya une bouche
les arrête
elle la recherche je pense que déjà
beaucoup beaucoup plus
l'élégance l'élégance à la française
et c'est sympathique juste j'aurais
juste qu'on voit un dernier truc des
génies du pas ça s'est passé dans les
rênes du shopping on a connaît tous
quelqu'un qui a un rire de canard ou un
rire de jeu c'est pas de game et ben
dont les rênes du shopping la dpj il ya
une fonction musumba oui mon ami elle
est sûrement me sebbar avis légaux
rigueur car il a découvert
on a dit on va faire une femme avec un
rire de corbeaux regardez c'est très
beau
on se croirait en pleine forêt regarde
il faut que ça plus court plus près du
camp c'est l'idéal pour elle oui bah
l'idéal serait de penser à faire un
choix de tenues plus qu'une heure 16 au
chrono on dit ça on dit rien
[Musique]
en fonction des lits du paf on peut pas
oublier de citer l'une des meilleures
d'entre nous d'entre vous sait mais
valérie benaïm hier je me suis penché
sur valérie bénaïm et pendant ces trois
jours valerie je redis elle est allée se
reposer nouvel ami de compagnie et ben
ali fall et n'importe où puisque c'était
à ouarzazate avec son chéri patoche
regarder on a récupéré les images
franchement pato chez vous vous êtes
trop mignon les médailles les patrons
malinois
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
trancher
[Applaudissements]